it was new year's eve
and i was doing my meet and greet i'm
shirtless and this guy is [ __ ] wasted
and he's like
he's like hey man can i get like two
minutes your time and
you know immediately in a meet and greet
you're like oh god goddammit yeah and
the bouncer's like hey moving on i go no
give me
give him a second and i go what's up
buddy he goes
all right i'm a fan do you know what
that means i said no he goes
it means when you succeed i succeed
i said i don't follow when he goes hear
me out hear me out
i don't got much going on in my life man
but i picked you
i picked you through all the podcasts
you're the guy that made me laugh the
hardest and you're my guy
i buy your merch i come to your shows
and when you succeed
i feel like i succeeded because i made
the right decision he was who you a fan
of and i went
like i'm a fan of i'm a fan of uh of
wilco's like my favorite band and he
goes
he goes when they when good things
happen don't you get excited for him i
go
yeah i do and he goes that's what a fan
is and then he said that and i started
going through of all the people i'm
fans of and i was like yeah that's so
[ __ ] so crazy like i like it like
yeah like like when you see
when you pick your people and then they
do something big you're like [ __ ] yeah
that's my guy and and and what is sad is
there are people that are too cool to be
fans
and i get that i won't use you because
you're here ben margera right
bam margera and ryan dunn those guy i am
i was legit a fan of ryan dunst like
legit
the [ __ ] that guy for whatever
[ __ ] reason he embodied
all the [ __ ] i liked like all of it
there was this [ __ ] time
when they were up on a scissor thing on
viva la bam and they were stuck up there
for like
[ __ ] four hours and then someone came
out and said
you guys had the keys up there and they
didn't realize they'd been up there for
four hours
and i was crying laughing that's when i
fell in love with those dudes yeah
so when i watch bam go through his tough
times
i get bummed out for him i do i get
bummed out for him and i'm like come on
buddy we got
we got this not you got that we got this
and then when i see him like
hanging out with his kid and being in a
good place skateboarding with his kid
or hitting a ramp and you go oh he's he
must be in good shape
because he's landing tricks i get
excited for him
his successes make me happy dude
once you subscribe to that and you get
that everything [ __ ] makes sense
yeah dude